we've heard multiple warnings in the
last few days that the NHS is facing
extreme pressure this winter and on
multiple fronts so what do the figures
show one measure of the Health Service
performance is a e waiting times which
have increased dramatically over the
last two years in November 2022 more
than 37 000 people waited more than 12
hours in a e before being admitted to a
hospital Department that's 34 times
higher than it was at the end of 2019.
the latest figures show there's also
been a sharp increase in the number of
people having to wait over an hour for
an ambulance look at the red line that's
2022. on Christmas Day the latest day
for which we have data more than one in
seven people waited more than an hour
for an ambulance that's almost 10 times
higher than in 2021 and 17 times higher
than in 2020 demand for beds is also
higher because there are more long-term
own patients than any of the three
previous years take a look at the third
graph over here it shows over the past
four years the number of beds taken up
by people who've been in hospital for
more than three weeks in the week
leading up to Christmas last year it was
almost 25 percent higher than it was in
2021 and 60 higher than it was in 2020.
so why is demand so high it's at least
partly because of the pressure created
by Rising flu cases let's look at the
flu admissions in the week leading up to
Christmas in 2021 there were just 34
people in hospital with flu each day and
only two of them required critical care
now let's look at a week leading up to
Christmas in 2022 there were
3746 patients each day in hospital with
flu with more than 260 of them in
critical care beds so we're seeing more
than a hundred times more people being
hospitalized with flu and requiring care
and they'll run up to Christmas compared
to the year before and that's all
happening as the Health Service faces a
staffing crisis as of September 2022
there were more than 133
000 job vacancies across the NHS and
around 11 of those vacancies are in
nursing with the nurses Union saying
poor wages and working conditions are
why so many are leaving the sector
now the government says it's doing all
it can to relieve the strains on the
Health Service but with multiple NHS
trusts declaring critical incidents a
winter of industrial action and the
pressure of flu and covert cases it
seems the NHS is in for a challenging
start to the new year